hey guys we get the 30th of me today my
name is josh mcdowell and here are my
top 5 favorite gaming related news
stories of the whole week let's get
going first up watchdogs has become
Ubisoft fastest selling game beating out
the franchise's of birth far cry and
Assassin's Creed you be announced at the
open-world action game sold through more
copies in the first 24 hours after
launch than any of their previous titles
the data was based on internal estimates
for all platforms but they wouldn't
share specific figures despite launch
issues and complications surrounding you
play it safe to say that overall the
publisher have done pretty well with
this one if you picked yourself up an
xbox one and you wanted to know a list
of games that are coming out this year
that you can grab a giant article on our
site has it covered Sony published their
list of PlayStation games earlier this
year but if you want to check out the
70-plus titles we dug up for Microsoft's
console that's the thing you can do the
list includes games like bungie's
destiny sunset overdrive that new halo
game and Cappie virus below as well as a
whole mess of other titles we got an
update on the order 1886 ready at Dawn's
ps4 exclusive and here's what you might
want to know the game grab is sort of a
delay to early 2015 and the dev
explained that they're going with 30
frames per second because even though
the thaumic looks at the game is trying
to emulate is 24 FPS that frame rate
didn't feel good to play there's also a
fairly sweet gameplay trailer to keep
you busy if you're excited for this one
so be sure to check that out next up all
the piracy seems to be happening and
it's targeting Wolfenstein the new order
according to a report from torrentfreak
the game has been downloaded more than a
hundred thousand times even though the
game is pretty popular with people who
want to download it for free apparently
the 43 gigabyte file size has been
enough to put some pirates Oh like
Elizabeth asda there are actually a
bunch of people who wanted to pay for
the game to which shot at the top of the
best-selling titles list on Steam laughs
week lastly a video for battlefield
hardline leaked this week and now we
know a bunch more things about it the
game is basically a cops and robbers
style concept with multiplayer modes
that are summed up into the following a
bank-robbing mode called heist a hostage
saving one called rescue hot wire which
is all about vehicle chases and blood
money where you fight over money and
presumably shed blood and keeping it
simple you can check out the video on
site for all the details but it's worth
knowing that the single-player campaign
revolves around a young miami detective
chasing down his old partners and EA are
trying to make LEvolution happen it's a
term again let me know in the comments
if you think battlefield hardline looks
any good and if you're still into the
series this week on site be sure to
check out our comparison of watch dogs
and Assassin's Creed on the gist
Hamlet's you know if watch dogs could
happen in real life and the rain and I
get our retro on with the 7th guest in
house Horace that is it for me this week
thanks for sticking around as always and
be sure to check in with us again on
Monday for a special surprise I hope you
have yourself a lovely weekend
you